une production du studio sfr
bienvenue sans filtre le broadcast qui
devront parce qu'on veut avec nos
invités dati je perds je chante avec moi
d'une plante en ce moment vous nous
écoutez nous regardent et peu importe
sur quelle plateforme on est dans
l'espace vous dois keaton ou trois
studios disponibles au studio sf6 ou
est-ce qu'on s'occupe de tout sauf du
contenu et vous arrivez ici que votre
contenu on s'occupe la technique la
production la post-production mixage
montage on s'occupe de vous mettre en
confiance notre équipe de techniciens
extraordinaire quatre jeunes africains
par le nicholl nicholl l'extraordinaire
vous met en confiance s'occupe de vous
guide dans votre processus y'a pas vous
avez pas besoin de temps à tête avec
quoi que ce soit on s'occupe de tout
vous voulez plus d'informations si vous
avez envie de lancer votre projet allé
au studio et 16 points 6 e ou écrivez
nous à info à commerciale sud yossef
points c'est à cette semaine baic dès
cette semaine très content de recevoir
l'artiste l'idiot qui peine ce qui est
idiot qui excusent mois alité jolie dieu
c'est lydia kempinski narcisse que
j'adore qui nous oppresse compostri
cette fenêtre qui fait de la musique
incroyable a lancé son nouvel album
depuis
déjà quelques semaines pour moi un album
original en sommes qu dation un album
qu'il faut écouter vraiment de manière
active
ça vaut la peine de faire cet effort là
de se mettre l'album de l'écouté
qui de la précipite je pense que c'est
la meilleure manière d'en retirer le
maximum de là même qui demande
concentration mais quelqu'un qu'on lui
donne ça vaut vraiment la peine il ya et
drôles et originales elles font en fait
une star des conversations sur son
processus créatif sur la musique sur le
sport aussi
une adepte des arts martiaux elles
prétendent aimer mais aussi donc et
parfois on peut penser qu'ils seraient
c'est ce qui fait que ce personnage le
final ces personnes le et multi facettes
et le fun donc belle conversation avec
nvidia on la remercie puis on vous
souhaite bonne équipe un bon pote casse
au pied le podcast de cette semaine et
présenté par auch lag hochelaga qui le
fournisseur officiel du studio sfr
produits alcoolisées et non alcoolisées
moi vous le savez il emmener parlait
déjà j'ai arrêté de boire de l'alcool ça
fait un petit bout pas catégoriquement
mais j'ai grandement grandement diminuer
ma consommation d'alcool les ménages
consomment les produits sans alcool
d'hochelaga la blonde sans alcool est
absolument incroyable 5 blonde en vie
mais j'y vois la budweiser
habituellement le team gut blonde
blagues et il aime ça et blanc j'aime
selon qui la blonde ça d'alcool et
schlag pauvret est incroyable à goutte
la bière blonde pour de vrai à bière
blanche d'hommes s'exclame sans alcool
aussi mais en plus des produits sans
alcool les avions la gamme de produits
nanos qui réussit nano blanche nano et
pied une année blanche des produits un
petit peu moins alcoolisés donc deux
points 5 % à peu près le pour leurs
canettes de nano mais tout le bon goût
des bières bien évidemment ils ont toute
leur gamme de produits alcoolisés des
bières jusqu'au c'est en son
nom par ceux qui nous écoutent qui vous
savez que j'adore les certitudes des
pubs découvert cela fait je préfère
ouvrir sa nouvelle il ya toujours ce
léger je trouve ça l'fun d'avoir un
petit goût plus sucré mais pas trop puis
le dépasser j'étais à côté sous selle
sur tout être de cet été ne savent
vraiment pas exception arcand si en plus
c'est l'anniversaire que j'ai à me
mettre sous le la danse ou le de ballet
du palais
sur les dix nouveaux celle souhaitée par
ashley qui sont à base de votre que donc
c'est pas banal comme une anti bol de
votre couche trop que le goût encore
plus
prononcée je trouve que c'est encore
plus agréable en tête en haut d'une
belle saveur on off h on apprend boisé
on orange sanguine y aussi les salles ce
liman dr schlaug sont vraiment banques
sont plus coûteux encore
moi j'adore ce cd comme du bonneteau
pétillante c'est rafraîchissant et
désaltérant mais on a le petit à petit
feu ni de petit clic de la ligue en même
temps c'est vraiment super on aime #owni
le 1er mai sentiment on est vraiment
contents de collaboration que l'action
menée si vous louez le studio vous avez
accès aux frites d'hochelaga les serbes
sur la base avocats sont disponibles qu
est ce que tu les autres d'aller
chercher tout dans un des près de chez
vous les biarrots cela et en épicerie
toute l'équipe cherchait à claques
prenez les consommer leurs produits qui
est à merci pour votre collaboration en
continu avec le studio est le podcast
aujourd'hui est présentée par
monsieur on adore on n'a pas toujours en
avant avec conviction les produits qu'on
croit et m'inscrire aux nouvelles offres
pour nous tout ce qui est incroyable en
fait c'est le meilleur package et rêveur
quand j'avais fait c'est le platine en
tant qu'aide 4.0 tadiotto et le lower
4.0 qui le trimer qui est le rasoir
électrique le will work will voit que
l'on sait pour les poêles dany l'equal
d'oreilles qui moi j'ai reprise est
franche un problème de toiles de nuit
quand que justin que je ne contrôle pas
ce jeudi l'emploi pour dîner soit on
veut passer ce qui apparaît comme un
spectre faire attention c'est pas donné
moi le vélo à que génère une vitre en a
donné une idée à qui des plus jeunes les
sergents de ma vie a changé ma vie je
t'ai radio point la blonde à m'arracher
pour donner à la mitaine c'est pas de
plan les ouates coeur ça donne jusqu'au
6 mai la liste de huawei il ya aussi
acquise à ce jour les pentes moi ça ici
le pad et wash et le shampoing deux
armes et ses mig mégots tout ça vient
avec l'odeur caractéristique
du domaine ce qui est un petit peu accru
mais honnêtement meilleur volley vaches
meurent chaque point que j'ai ça bien
que le déodorant ça vient aussi avec le
déodorant pour base le fameux drapeau
belge avec le disent prêts tonifiant
pour les barrages matches la tête aux
pieds avec même skate même le parfum
freemium de minsk et
puis la fin de semaine passée je suis
allé au spectacle de refuse du solde
final et sainte hélène je me suis fait
comme complimenté par des purs inconnus
au moins trois fois sur mon autre parce
que jeter dans la foule comme ça avec
mon parfum medicaid honey demain
c'est le ji était paul gaultier par goce
le dancefloor qui soulève qu'elle est
qu'ils n'ont dérange tout le monde s'en
doute est elle un
petit peur des gens passent à côté de
simples sites web sans bon minsk et
qu'on a encore
[Musique]
des images et du band 3 platinum paquet
4.0 au show de rue faut juste aller le
code promotion bronze jeu on n'a pas les
codes promo c'est sans fil 20% de rabais
livraison gratuits aux frais ça à
quelqu'un à acheter là pour vous c'est
le cadeau du soleil avec mercy mindscape
puis bon paquet bonne écoute
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
howie à lui le
dgs est de décrire qu'est ce qui est de
sa pensée pour les gens qui nous écrit
on veut mettre la france sous le chapeau
d'entrée de jeu avec on va faire une
heure et demie sans trop cher pour moi
c'est ça mon chapeau mon chapeau aux
samoa mairie
comment tu lui c'était un cadeau c'est
un cadeau chalet à pogo note catherine
pogonat du canada qui innovent is you
can't say no te lis l'iedom des cadeaux
de la guilde remake non mais en fait
c'était jeudi costume fait qu'ils ont
dit les jeudis on se costument tout le
temps fait que l'oeil monde il va
falloir que tu costumes tout s'était
fait que les mondanités le costume est
avec comme une table avec ce soir j'ai
choisi le chapeau à une équipe dans le
fond qui est ce c'est un costume
vraiment moi je costumes et encore des
personnages
de personnes qui
boivent a évoqué les gars qui aime le
démontrer ouais ben cheikh gueule
ouais ouais bon il y avait des chapeaux
de même le sang
coule commencent à voler ça va bien mais
je vois même pas dans une école un
pauvre est pourquoi je sais c'est
justement parce que le ce a énoncé que
je suis en général sans gluten oh ouais
ouais fake je vais plus avec le groupe
jund trouve très bon exemple vous avez
vous des marques de bière préférée au
site l'apa d'oiseaux ah ouais ok classe
a toujours été de la budweiser pleut
maintenant je bois plus de l'accueil
fait que j'achète la budweiser sans
alcool qui sinon ici au studio on a de
la schlague la schlague est vraiment ch
l'axé la compagnie soeur de gluten ben
oui
oui c'est les commanditaires officiels
ce trou dans mon en ouvrir une tente où
on a des six avec les skis en agence et
sur la fin c'est ça la clé de mer bières
ou bac pro
mais peut-être que ceux à base de lait
mettons les cersois base à votre cas est
il du gluten nada
c'est sûr que non non non c'est de la
pomme de terre
une invention norvégienne
dans votre cas
la vote
moi j'suis curieux quelques matches
c'est sûr c'est maintenant l'histoire
est slumdog millionaire ou est ce qui
arrive à un jeu télévisé pleut toutes
les questions ont un endroit dans sa vie
donc
comment tu sais que la voiture ne
mangeons d'origine ça arrive commente on
chante sa reconnaissance ah ben je pense
juste une culture générale
tu te rappelles passé quant à ce jeu
je peux me vanter mais je connais
beaucoup de choses
et non mais je sais que non je pense
j'avais tiré vers quelqu'un vidéo sur
youtube c'est l'histoire de la de
l'alcool en russie qui est comment la
vodka dans le fond n'était pas que c'est
pas une invention russie une invention
d'origine
avoue qu'on s'est vus elle dit a dit
qu'elle te faisais du yuzu brizolier
ouais ce que c'est toujours le cas ouais
disque les mains pour les gens qui se
sont trahis pas seulement les cheveux
droit dans la ville extrêmement droit
puisse céder si le résultat de mes
boxeurs bride hockey avec elle j comme
j'ai dormi avec qui a acheté fatigue et
puis c'est s'agit pas les cheveux frisés
dans la vie et puis je me les aplati
peut non plus être inauguré ces 10 pour
ceux qui s'entraînent
les cheveux bloc mais je suis à toi
aurait grosse cession de muay thaï a
commencé rue dans ta vie les combats ce
genre de formation mais c'est mon
premier batteur qui s'appelait stéphane
lemieux puis dans le fond lui était
excusé
maintenant je pense que je m'attaque
comme dit mon premier bateau mais je
pensais pas un joueur de patrick
genre le premier gars qui m'a battu
s'appelait telle personne genre il
faisait des études souhaitait qu'un
palais je me défende un salarié
non c'est
non non c'est vraiment léger
et le monde remark the past était
ceinture bruno 500 noir qui épie pendant
qu'on faisait des pauses cd fois
sécuritaire de vendre mon été ternie
puis pendant qu'on a les gaz et les
fonds se battait un peu puis j'ai juste
trouvé ça drôle j'étais courageux
m'inscrire à un couvre lit finalement
c'est tellement le fun c'est tellement
cool mais il y avait un peu plus which
par la boxe thaï
mais les deux c'est vraiment le fun leur
cible mais si ceux ci étaient axées sur
le mouvement et joji dessous c'est
vraiment plus complexe parce qu'il est
vraiment des tonnes et des tonnes de des
techniques que tu peux faire le monde
est un peu plus simple dans le sens où
il est moins de move mais ça non plus de
puissance pire ouais c'est ça fascinant
c'est un monde de la discipline quand
même pas mal de sport le corps une fois
tant fait personnelle et bien le tu vois
le chalet deux trois fois la semaine
passée deux fois cette semaine mais
c'est directement qu'une coupe de cours
après s'il faut que tu seras travers un
peu mais c'est vraiment le fun ça
canalise vraiment si des fois je sais
que j'ai des pensées qui partent par
tous bien pressé je fais mon heure et
demie c'est super genre forçant pigé le
temps j'ai comme l'espace mental de
penser à rien d'autre les ampoules de
biens il souvent je reviens chez nous
que j'ai des idées des idées que tu peux
des idées créatrices gens disaient tu
peux appliquer la whey jusqu'à mon
mental et que me relaxe ya juste comme
de la place pour des nouvelles choses
est ce que comme caen et des stresseurs
puis des petites sociétés qui arrive
c'est qu'on ne peut pas de place pour
être créatif je trouve que c'est comme
s'il faut faire le ménage balayé puis je
trouve que le sport ça ça aide vraiment
ce qu'ils savaient de servir une
discipline de vie ben c'est comme pour
moi mettons faire de la scène peut-être
moins du studio mais faire la scène
c'est vraiment la même chose que faire
du sport de compétition ensemble c'est
comme si ton corps c'est un travail il
faut que tu fasses attention il ya des
trucs et mettons en tant que chanteur je
peux pas faire si je peux genre crié le
soir piperno envoyer des affaires qu'il
faut que ce soit qu'une chose du genre
ouais c'est sa fonction en forme en
général pis et de la discipline aux
cibles c'est quand même c'est sûr qu'ils
ont et qu'ils réussissent à faire
exactement ben pas exactement ce que je
fais mais j'imagine genre à réussir dans
le métier puis qui sont verts depuis
aucune discipline puis honnêtement ces
gens là font chier pour nous des gens
qui travaillent genre mais comme pour
moi c'est juste ce travail puis la
discipline
j'écoutais dont entrevue à l'émission
l'émission de nicolas houlette de
communiqué qu'elle s'appelle jeanne
collections il aurait eu ce soir ouais
et cela s'est pas fait du bruit c'est
puis venant c'est plus du bruit c'est
pas nouveau ça non plus
je m'appelle plus brefs tt a été invité
le pour une courte entrevue puis jetée
entendait faire l'apologie du travail
justement puis je veux qu'on en discute
d'un petit peu plus parce qu'ici au sans
filtre on est des adeptes évidemment de
la discipline de veepee du du sport et
l'activité physique puis dé la routine
maintenant accomplir des choses même si
ces affaires leçon artistique dans ton
cas où l'entrepreneuriat de mon côté
pitié la discipline est nécessaire puis
souvent comme nicolet le mentionner dans
cette entrevue le caecum glorifier de
sans casser on dirait dans le milieu
artistique d'avoir l'air de ne pas
travailler puis ça viennent facilement
puis de l'espèce d'image de jean leloup
qui composent une toune
en une minute jo parce qu'il n'ya pas de
phare sur un ton neutre un fake toit
pour toi la discipline c'est une
capitale j'imagine dans ta vie tu as tu
toujours été comme ça ouais tout le
temps j'ai toujours été très disciplinés
quand je voulais faire quelque chose je
savais que seuls moyens d'accomplir
c'était juste de travailler travailler
travailler tu puis de juste d'accorder
du temps dans ta vie pour faire ce
qu'ils de développer des skieuse de
poche oistamo choix de devenir le
meilleur dans les trucs des croquis pour
accomplir telle idée il faut que je
passe par le fait que je cache kraft
jusqu'à ce que je sois bon pied et je
dire jean leloup c'est sûr qu'il avait
investi de sauter en même temps à trois
heures du matin va appeler ses musiciens
puis va direct 8 je sais comme
évidemment genre personne qui fasse
aujourd'hui le mérou bataille je sais
pas le métier c'est comme c'est quand
même quelqu'un qui travaille tout le
temps ils se fréquentaient
alors tu peux pas m'appeler à trois
heures de la nuit
broken side mais encore le 7e temps des
relations de pouvoir la malle
heureusement ce milieu là c'est comme
des ctt le pouvoir d' employer des gens
qui d'avoir un espèce d'état la proue
d'un bateau qui fonctionne il ya
toujours des gens qui vont être autour
de toi tu fais que ça te donne une
excuse d'agir comme une merde c'est ce
qui est super technique dans les airs
c'est que souvent genre le résultat est
tellement up qui tout montrer que tout
le monde ses crises de caisse que mener
au résultat
puis tout le monde des gens à qui j'en
ai huit personnes en épuisement
professionnel dans l'équipe mais genre
on veut juste les remplacer puis
continue et puis continuer parce que les
résultats et le riz les gens veulent la
nourriture culturel du puits déjà
mettons tout était quand même mettons
comprends ton exemple quand même un une
proue de bateau qui sont attrayantes
pour tout les musiciens qui voudraient
travailler avec un projet comme cet
effet que s'il y en a un qui fait peur
aux jumelages une qui me jugent positon
coach sportif est sûre le mettons dans
un exemple d'un projet comme celui là
j'imagine que beaucoup de monde qui
attendent l'appel le tuer si un axe ils
ont pu le travail là dessus ouais métier
je peux le team les gens avec qui je
travaille j'ai vraiment comme une
famille puis c'est que ça m'en prendrai
vraiment beaucoup pour d'ivoire se sont
jamais vus comme travail et des
relations puis que tout le monde
travaille un peu pour essayer de trouver
des terrains communs mais c'est pitié
non plus ma structure c'est pas un ben
non pull je peux décider de changer
l'équipe à n'importe quel moment jean je
le fais pas parce que en ce moment je
satisfaite mais comme sahin chose qu'un
band qui doit tout le temps faire des
compromis et puis abandonnée à quelque
chose qui fonctionne plus
mais
toi étant justement le lieu
le capitaine du bateau bien dans la
neige rails dont la magie du bateau
jusqu'à sergent c'est quelque chose qui
peut arriver justement de thé avec la
notoriété avec avoir un projet qui qui
fonctionne puis un projet qui est wawa
qui systèmes existants est ce que toi tu
te doublement attention ne pas devenir
cette personne lui qui pourrait
mal tourner
à west ham pour ça oui c'est tout le
temps comme une bête que je suis quand
même inquiet le narcissisme fo
totalement cash faire attention parce
que je suis particulièrement est
prédisposé mais quand même les gens qui
font de la scène quand même là on a le
capitaine puis tout le sport en
capitaine c'est un peu comme le boxeur
c'est un peu comme le boxeur pts comme
toute l'équipe les entraîneurs les
commanditaires les comme toute l'équipe
mais le boxeur s'est quand même c'est
celui qu'on voit mais comme il ya
personne qui voit l'entraîneur qui a
personne qui voit comme toute l'équipe
de massothérapeute puis l'équipe de
nutritionnistes puis c'est comme vu que
t'étais la personne qui est visible ce
que ça donne laisser passer des fois
passé comme les gens ils peuvent te
pardonner plus facilement ou au
contraire ne pas te pardonne et puis
être faux king déçu mais c'est comme si
j'étais comme une espèce de capital de
sympathie et puis moi je fais vraiment
tension puis 10 ont tissé des trucs
vraiment simple jusqu'à mes tongs en jeu
dans une conversation avec des gens
j'essaie de comme peu trop parlé de mes
chier tout comme juste m'intéressait
honnêtement aux autres genres mes
collègues et des anglophones qui ont
aucune crise idée de ce que je fais je
dis et comme il ya plein de monde que je
m'entoure que je sens qu'ils sont pas
des yes men qui sont peu genre à lydiane
thibault woillet ces genres six courses
à faire encourager mais faut pas que
j'ai besoin de ça pour continuer à faire
mes choses faut juste que comme j'assume
je me regarde dans la glace puisque
c'est ce que je veux faire c'est nice
qui gratte j'ai pas besoin de personnes
qui sont comme athée tellement coullier
on veut çi les gens dire que mieux rien
c'est vraiment les gens sont peu mal
intentionnés mais des fois j'en suis
moins vite pourrait pour être cool gens
ils m'invitent parce qu'ils trouvent ça
cool est mon ami le nombre de personnes
qui m'écrivent pour actualiser ce qu'on
peut aller soupire c'est que du monde
que ce cas n'est pas moins que sky
peuvent si comme tu me connais peu pour
que tu veux qu'on ait souper ensemble
c'est juste parce que je suis tu veux
que je vais natation horrible parce que
je coupe le genre c'est comme ça c'est à
parler j'ai fui comme la paix cela je
peux faire sauf quand c'est payant on
décrète une geek pour instagram qui ne
voulaient pas que je joue de la musique
les voulais juste que ce soit le genre
depuis que je joue de la musique et que
j'ai apporté - et panne est juste
branché playa vais me tourner sans
paroles plus chanté par un siège en
karaoké tout le monde sur l'histoire 8c
mal à piger genre j'étais tellement bien
payé pour ça l'argent est pas la vraie
musique ses collègues écoulé trois
règles là les trois choses à cacher le
de ton travail à l'université que tu as
utile pour les la question se situe dit
louis guigou non mais c'est plus la
perspective d'une brique et perspectives
métis juste et dans un contexte des
musées professionnelle etc sont engagés
sur un tour
c'était
lytro les deux lettres au facteur à ma
tante facteur 10 ou à deux des trois
tests du détroit c'est comme si good
enough mettons tout elle est trop belle
encore mieux souhaitent apprendre
quelque chose qui est sûre au dessus à
votre iphone
si tu vaux dessus ce fait
c'est tout de suite après quelque chose
petit iphone georges
pu le faire chier
mais tu peux apprendre quelque chose
puis on peut voir la peine qu'on
apprendra quoi faire quand tu te fais
chier
c'est payant à bettié me faire chier
deux fois ça c'est nécessaire sans
apprendre ce agissements ouais
mais bon geek brune défaite de ses gains
et figuig brune pour aujourd'hui en fait
de moins en moins attendre
pour
j mais justement il ya eu certaines
dettes et eaunes
hughton c'est là qu'elle jeu sans me
souvenir le thème où tu parle justement
de cette espèce de ses impostures la
deuxième inquiet
si c'est pas ce thème le exactement
combien je parlais mais l'espèce de
l'effet d'avola d'esquisser les quelque
chose telle espèce des vols d'appareils
de l'artiste et si je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup d'artistes ont trait sur tout
non j'allais dire surtout la nouvelle
génération mais je pense que c'est de
toujours ou est ce qui t on
il ya vraiment une conscience
du
personnage qu'on essaie de créer d'une
mythe qu'on essaie de créer du de
l'espèce d'image qu'on essaie d'envoyer
justement être cool mais ton je pense
que ça fait
beaucoup partie de com
du hype d'un projet où c'est justement t
elle ce projet ce projet lié colas
article écoutez je pense que si je passe
beaucoup d'artistes qui l'entretiennent
consciemment mais tant pis de
de montrer ces vulnérabilités ou de
montrer que mon coeur pour quelque chose
de montrer qu'on sait qu'ils respectent
quelque chose
toujours la chose la plus cool tu sais
parce que je trouve ça le fun qui n'a
pas dans une tour parce que si c'est
comme j'ai peut-être l'air de manquer
c'est que ça fait la file devant mes
shows
la tige la crise tout
en même temps faut pas que ça
définissent c'est comme si comme des
côtes et il faut vraiment être
nonchalant son sens que si quelqu'un est
qu un moment gachi themsche en amont
avec toi tu je donne mon crise et je
dois faire comme acquis sénat et
services ont traité le fait qu'ils aient
comme des gros line up c'est comme
acquiescé nice mais comme ça va pas
comme bouzid et mon ego je vais rester
comme une personne normale qui fait ses
courses tous les aquitains qui dit je
t'aime je te rameau avec toi ouais
c'est personnel tu ne connais pas non si
c'est la personne que tu es ittifaq ceci
comme tu peux pas le prendre comme un
rire le thème parce que ça met les gens
qui viennent et échoppes qui tourne
c'est m toute fois qu'il touchait un
témoin mais tellement juste avec ariane
même pas moi qui écrit les textes mais
tire itunes conte de travailler ensemble
quand on les joue devant du monde
puisqu'elle monde triple les champs
à chaque fois un peu comme voir quitter
ça existe et piqué béton
on écrit sud est rien et il n'y avait
rien il avait ajouté qu'il est aussi
beau at-il qu'ils jugent bout on sait
botter le cul au s'est d'ailleurs offert
des toons on va travailler sur on va les
sortir plus ça fait un effet domino
jusqu à ce qu est à manille se retrouve
sur un state ce jeu-là musée puis du
monde d'en face qui ont écouté les toons
des gens qui sont le pichon qui pose mes
soirées où ça mais ça me fabregas à
chaque fois 100% mais être réunis autour
de l'objet c'est ce qu'il ya de plus
précieux c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
beau d'être réunis autour de la chanson
tiens moi ce qui me fait peur c'est le
de mélange et je pisse que j'ai fait
mais les gens y soit cas où on t'aime
mais c'est comme dans ma tête j'ai tout
le temps comme on aime quelque chose
ensemble mais c'est pas moitié parce que
sinon ça s'en vient vraiment off qui
sait comme pendant la pandémie il ya
plein de gens qui étaient comment on
sent mieux faire des spectacles ce que
payet le titan qui peuvent faire des
shows le titan 8e faire dire que tout
genre le monde t'aime même si c'est que
c'est comme genre développé une
dépendance puis souvent c'est des gens
qui ont un peu moins confiance en eux ou
qu'ils ont co mais je sais pas il
faisait beau vie au secondaire placé
comme ils trouvent ça c'est comme la
panacée de lamotte monde mais mais pour
toute ma vie mais c'est comme mettons
qui arrive de quoi à l'hectare est de
faire ce qu'elle dépend limites de ce
qu'est ce qui se passe peut être ton
individu est parti je m'attribue
toutefois content la gratification
externe que se fait avec la
procrastination et aurait comme en
commun ce que tu te valorise quand les
gens te valorise lui mettant un créateur
de contenu qui se fait chaque dans son
comté qui sont intenses oui oui toujours
juste il ya des exemples évidemment je
ne met personne pour pas danser duché
inutilement des métiers jack des gens
qui est leur affaire mais fonctionne la
ferme à leurs affaires marchent plan
mené mais ton créateur a convenu ce bon
exemple la mettez des écoutes deviennent
misérable pilotes les la raison pourquoi
tu existais c'est à dire des abonnés la
vente qui suivait de suivre plus
probablement que ça doit donner un bon
coup quand même
à comme ton identité parce que pendant
tellement longtemps
tue s'identifie par le monde qui
truffent parce que c'est la nature même
du milieu
il faut être capable de s'identifier
parce que tu fais à 20 mais le faire toi
même envers toi même c'est ceux qui le
peuvent pas vivre dans le regard des
autres non c'est surtout une mauvaise
idée sauf que j'ai l'impression que
vivent le regard des autres un peu comme
ça c'est un peu le
le ca en forme boomer pire mais c'est un
peu la façon par défaut avec laquelle on
vit de notre ville tu y mets ton juste
un exemple t on savait que je venais sur
le podcast et georges ont fait des
recherches parce qu'on songe on se
prépare pour chercher nos recherches on
se prépare à recevoir nos invités c'est
juste faire inquiéter leurs bâtons et
jets pas il ya dix mille personnes qui
suivent sur instagram c'est comme ça
tiens salut valeur c'est un chiffre
quand même qui est réel mais salle une
valeur les gars moi je vois ton corps
des trafiquants des 10000 personnes
samedi quelque chose mais c'est quand on
est un peu par défaut lancement de l' os
chronique
catégoriser par des des chiffres ne veut
partir mais il faut être faut être
capable de s'en défaire le faire qu'ils
vont essayer tout une valeur haute que
celle là qui juste qui appartient aux
autres dans le fond de sa poche mais
normes et mensonges comment je les ai
redit en fait parce que tout y est comme
you lie dickens qui l'artiste qui projet
de musée qui est les équipes en ski la
personne dit
qu'il disait keynes qui le projet au jeu
très fort lors sa grâce auquel didier
pinsky la personne
je la connais pas cette personne là
connaît apporte woippy les gens proches
pic c'est ce qui fait que ça porte le
même nom on confond c'est tout à fait ce
que je pense mais en même temps je ne
sais pas ce que la création et c'est
tout et c'est quand même moi qui parle
de choses qui ne sont arrivés c'est
comme je fais des clés dans lequel shell
a aimé mais ces genres c'est souplesse
pour ce casting
celaa difficile à faire cette séparation
lutte c'est son nom mais c'est juste que
c'est pas vrai que les gens c'est les
gens peuvent qu'avec mon nom qui peuvent
connaissent que je fais puis c'est vrai
que c'est très proche de la personne que
je suis tu sais juste qu'ils me
connaissent pas personnellement mais je
fais quelque chose qui est quand même
extrêmement proches le jeu vraiment pas
dans la fiction le
oui
peu importe qu est-ce qu on crée qu'on
soit dans la fiction ou non je dis ça
sort tout le temps exact se de toi tu es
un pote de l'artiste que ce soit au taux
fixe de l'autobiographie ou une fiction
c'est comme ces choses qui rentrent et
puis quelque chose du muet véhicules
puissent est ressorti
méthodique et qu'en même temps je pense
que
pour prendre l'exemple la personne qui
dit qu' avec hatem oui c'est juste que
met-on mode cas ça m'arrive
à cause de mes tantes podcast que j'en
dise je viens de m'avoir piles sont
quand même j'ai passé qui j'ai de la
misère à le prendre parce que je me dis
c'est construit quand même une des deux
mois sur wii je le juge aux plus ou
moins ce que tu me vois pas où j'étais
inquiet quand j'arrive ici je tends
maudet je vais pas castrés puis georges
dans le mode de jeu puis quand même
conscient de ce que je projette métier
moi laissez personne l'omi mais qui
travaillent ou mes angoisses ou mieux
quoi que ce soit c'est peu mais t'es pas
obligée de le prendre je n'ai pas envie
je prends pas tuer jusqu'à ok mais ce
que démontre le podcast
ce montant puisque avant 6 heures
juste les jours de séparation justement
pratiquer comme s'arrêter demain matin
il faut quand même que l'individu sans
le projet ou sans le côté public du truc
choix break moi même puisque s'arrêter
du jour au lendemain et puis quand même
être réhabilité d'où l'importance
d'avoir des hobbies c'est vraiment cool
d un billet que ce soit les arts
martiaux ou le scrapbooking de se
réaliser dans d'autre chose toi la série
a juste 24 heures dans une journée mais
comme c'est cool d'avoir des amis qui
ont pas apparaître la business pied que
citoyen choix conscient d'avoir des
collègues qui ont aucune idée ce que tu
fais pour devenir maçon puis comme
déconnecté voulait me voir nettement je
suis cool je te laisse j'arrive qui je
suis jamais que mais a été genre sont
pas fans de rien jusqu'où ils font leur
vie puis il y en a une qui avocate bien
qu'ils étudiants comme sur scène depuis
un moment donné il me voit sur des
billets le brûle graisse et tu es tu toi
sur le billboard le giga loiret ce moine
a tué genre ça finit là qui on parle
d'autre chose lehmann autres sujets qui
sont intéressants sauf moi mais oui
c'est ce qu'ils soient feu sauf aussi
j'aurais
j'ai pas lutter toutes les discussions
de musiciens de genre au tel ou tel truc
c'est bon tu sais le truc c'est moins
bon genre est telle qu'il termine ici
comme moi non plus tout ça ils aiment de
musiciens tellement charles ça fait
juste par une musique guillemets c'est
cool c'est le fun mais genre je me sers
parler de l'existence la pomme de terre
ou de la vodka je me sépare les deux
pleines afin c'est toute une expérience
mais ce c'est je pense c'est vraiment
c'est tellement un bon point de
deux sites sont entourés de monde qui
ont rien en commun et que touba rien en
commun
dexter menée maison le corps des valeurs
similaires aux siennes même des mets de
quelqu'un qui vient pas du même monde
que tu puis de s'intéresser à ce monde
lorsque tout le monde
travaille tout le monde fait quelque
chose le tri fait que genre tout on
travaille pas plus important que le
travail de l'avocate de cacolac avocate
c'est oublier que développe des codes
l'outil de travail sont aussi importants
que ça rejoint moins de moitié
globalement ce code l'homme et son sens
calisti fait genre de pouvoir
s'intéresser à ce
moi il n'y a rien de pire qu attaquer
qu'un maton qui qui qui écoutent tous
n'ont pas de casque non moi c'est quand
même puis j'adore ces gens là merci
beaucoup le trim et genre parce que il
veut pas on va parler de tout on va
parler des podcasts vraiment les
podcasts g vivre je les suis dedans
lengelé on a on le fait dans ce moment
le tien fait qu'après ça c'est comme les
conversations là une fois qu'on les
hurlus puis quand je reviens chez nous
je fais pas de podcasts le fait d'être
quelqu'un qui me parle de ça c'est le
fun quand sature de trois secondes merci
beaucoup mais après cinq ans et comme
j'étais arrivé l'autre fois justement
dans un événement où est ce qu'il ya un
gars qui est venue s'asseoir à côté de
moi qui a déjà créé l'événement au
complet pour me parler d'eux et et
atterrissent business et relégations
minutes 26 et l'épisode de séquelles je
comprends mal que ça te rejoins moi en
ce moment j'ai envie de me tourner vers
l'autre personne qui te dit un cinquième
année de résidence en sais pas quoi que
je connais pas je posais des questions
sur son affaire à lui parce que ça
m'intéresse pas mal plus que de parler
quelque chose que j'ai déjà vécu et puis
je pense que c'est vraiment nécessaire
pour avoir une carrière prolongée de ces
daniel bélanger catimini site qui nous a
parlé de lui dans son monde le nepad
musiciens c'est lui fallait mais ses
amis c'est des vieux amis qui avaient
qui sont pas musiciens puis vie avec
puis jarrier woippy a pas de musique
constamment c'est plus la musique c'est
une partie de sa vie mais s'intéresse à
tout plein aux affaires dans le monde
dit si bien qu'une carrière prolongé au
québec c'est bien lui
j'aime tellement daniel on joue ensemble
à 9 sausheim et je joue avant lui faut
que je trouve un moyen de avant je
faisais un cover détend foule tu serais
tellement coup ce n'est chanter avec moi
je vais essayer de j'ai essayé de
corrompre quelqu'un pour avoir comme un
contact ouais j'aime tellement mais
c'est vrai c'est vrai ce que tu dis que
tu apprends tellement plus en fermant
tiger en général écoutez
l'écoutent puis la curiosité
les deux souvent avec locle s'est posé
question puis que tu utilises la réponse
c'est pas bon mais dont la curiosité
puis de prendre le temps d'écouter puis
après sur le nombre d'affaires que tu
connais de plus
il y avait un gars de manger avant lui
les singles les plus curieux que je
connaisse c'est probablement
pour les ces raisons la négo les plus
intelligents
tête de l'octavia qui devient ta culture
générale
j'adore écouter je pose des questions
j'écoutais réponse c'est ce
qui je te poses des questions se posent
des questions comme je suis honnêtement
intéressés par les choses de la vie
enfin quand donc processus de farce
album le ca comment cibler combien de
temps a commencé le 12 ans et non mais
ça a commencé dès que j'ai sorti 1er
juin c'est comme tout le temps processus
d'écriture du tout le temps trend a
griffonné piana
way défilé texte qui prennent trois ans
écrit le psycho respecte pas le moment
de dire qu'il faut jusqu'aux zones
albums georges maison pendant un mois
c'est comme c'est un temps que tenu du
petit j'y crois peu ce et je vais aller
cinq jours dans un chalet ça marche pas
ça marche tellement peu pour moi
l'espace est autobiographique mais truc
aussi fixé comme qu'est ce que je vive
dans un chalet à parfum du bourg
j'arrive à rien se passer mon voyage
intérieur mais jean non c'est juste
comme je vis des trucs il se passe des
trucs riches comme aux magouilles
duceppe a ensuite coiffé que je vais
jusqu'à écrire de quoi pied sassou fur
et à mesure le cpo six mois plus tard ah
oui la fois que des fois attiré des
textiles reste ouvert mais ton six mois
plus tard je veux faire comme un
ajustement que j'avais quand même dans
le fond tu es la face ça m'a fait
comprendre le truc là mais comme away
normalement et des textes peuvent rester
ouverts pendant trois 3 ans puis en est
qui peuvent être close et en deux
semaines
ce que tu viens de dire le maintenant
sûr que j'écris souvent dans un chalet a
pourfendu bois maintenant la sortie mais
j'ai fait en vo bûcher sortie jusqu'à 1
rue de cernay
cette prise en sortie des noms mais
cachée de la cité je fais ma maîtrise en
création de terrain ah ouais puis en
sortant de là c'est quand même hacker
ménage c'est écrire mais genre mais cinq
dernières années
sont était passé à apprendre à écrire
fait sur quoi j'écris sur que j'écris
maintenant que chez comme un cri rejet
les techniques mais là c'est la foire
que j'ai vécu c'est d'apprendre comment
écrire fait que charles j'ai rien à dire
j'ai rien vu j'ai rien à dire et fait
classer comme charles viii voyage
vittavi en compte déjà 1 connecte avec
d'autres gens qui a fait trois blessés
blesse pigeât tu vas apprendre pour
avoir quelque chose à dire la presse qui
est pas mal plus pertinent d'avoir
quelque chose à dire que de savoir bien
écrire c'est aussi savoir je pensais
développer les deux comme voir dans
quelque chose qui pour un serait banale
mais tout tu vois quelque chose ou un
mais des fois il ya des faux est affaire
banale qui sont banales pour tout le
monde puis les cordes à linge les corps
d'armées je le sais barbouille est assez
banal mais bref ce cas et surtout est
sûrement quelqu'un car de faire quelque
chose de beau avec le concept des cordes
à linge je sais juste moche peut voir je
peux être un poète du quotidien
j'aime ce que les enfants et pique ses
matons mais oui comme tu dis c'est comme
faire les hfc sortir puis pas avoir
d'idée d'entreprise
de comptabiliser les choses comprend le
feraient la demande mais top 10 des
fêtes du port du
support des compagnies de truc que
personne n'a besoin [ __ ] est capable dé
vendre parce que tu as appris comment
les vendre maintenant mais ça fait
signer compagnie que tout le monde a
déjà vu qui existent déjà
fait souvent du matériel a du mondial
n'ont pas besoin des mots ne tue
personne porte s'est
fait que tu peux passer des fois trois
ans sur un texte mettant pour revenir
après puis l'heure la revisiter ps que
des fois tu les laisses de côté parce
qu'il parle plus du tout que trois
hommes tant qu'interprète il raisonne en
toi quelque chose de nouveau et non des
fois c'est plus des blocages comme c'est
un peu comme quand il fait des mots moi
je fais beaucoup de mots fléchés lancer
maintenant il y en a un qui bug que ces
quatre lettres fuck ça es tu leur ferme
souvient lendemain comme acquis ça
débloque je trouve le truc pas si comme
c'est super
littéraire c'est super dans le français
mais si aussi mathématiques dans la
mesure où il ya comme des liens logiques
entre les mots qui commet hilson puis la
musique c'est que pour moi c'est très
géométrique c'est comme des trucs des
symétries mettons qui seul est
symétrique juste avant ça en faisant des
calculs fait que c'est comme si j'en lis
labs se répondent les unes les autres
c'est comme une consonne veux pas avoir
le même le la même résonance qu une
voyelle t'es ok c'est plus comme un coup
de tonnerre c'est plus comme une
percussion puis à huy où c'est plus
qu'un genre des cours des strings la
faire avec dans le fond c'est juste de
faire de faire match était consomme avec
le beat
tempi que tout serait aussi fait que
c'est quand même pour moi c'est des
constructions logique c'était
extrêmement léger qu'un morceau le fond
et peut être même sans dire illogique
mais plus dans dans l'émotion dans le
centime et apprécié quand même un
travail de reconstruction mécanique à
fond un peu comme de l' architecture tu
peux inventer n'importe quoi mais faut
que ça tient faut que les billets sont
en bonne place dans sa marche pas et où
tu peux faire que jeu d'avants facteur
puisque personne n'a jamais vu mais il
faut aussi que les gens cash soit
capable de lire genton bâtiment c'est
quoi la laitue des états c'est une femme
ou le but c'est justement que ce soit
aux quads comme les marches du musée
d'art contemporain au musée des
beaux-arts sont comme sont grosses
demain plaît tout le monde essaye de les
gravir mais ces foules à redouter mais
c'est comme si tu es sur le but de
darche est sur rush pitt soit comme auch
et démarche et je me suis passée juste
aller en plus houleux 4 2 mois puis j'ai
passé car voyant
son comme trop longue pour wii pour deux
marches mais trop court pour une marie
leisen
d'après effectivement je me sens pas
cette réflexion là guest que si vous lui
parce que c'est top aucun architecte in
the right man
fait la sonorité qu'est ce qui vient
avant le propos août des sons mettons
qui trouve les consonnes petit robert
est là qu il s en prend déco percus et
vous savez de deux temps par house
emprunt ihu et ces caisses qui ont remis
mais ne s'est pas aussi super
consciencieux mais non mais mettons
c'est drôle parce que 1er juin premier
album j'ai vraiment tout composer avec
guide qui le j'ai beaucoup composé sur
mon ipad en fait cela dépend de ma mère
qui m'avait donné jusqu'à manquera
jamais tueuse eceh puis finalement
thunder que soins qu'on était en tournée
dans l'auto avant de son chèque je sais
pas quoi souvent j'avais mon petit patch
acrobaties jeu peut-être partir un beat
fait que beaucoup de jeunes que j'ai
écrit jean dans l'avion venant de france
où comme dans des endroits random grâce
à sa ipad le puis je pense que j'ai plus
j'ai plus comment c'est une avec des
beats que pour l'album précédent qui
était 1er juin ou est-ce que ça va en
plus la guide je pense que ça va plus ça
plus fait que j'ai une écriture
percussive il
entend aussi que tu sais c'est plus une
musique axée sur les big l'insee ouais
plus que des chansons attentes
j'écoute et je les réécoute est ton
album un matin en courant puis
ça ça m'a vraiment parce que deux c'est
si rare maintenant dans ma ville et
moment où est ce que j'ai l'espace
mental pour écouter des auteurs
compositeurs interprètes le parce que
quand je joue de la musique maintenant
c'est surtout de la musique
instrumentale juste pour me concentrer
mais tant pis le deux semaines andy
fletcher qui bondissent de depeche mode
est décédé je suis comme retombée
mais ça a été un gros ben pour moi
secondaire
cgpi
qui en écoutant ton album un matin en
écoutant dans l'album j'ai vraiment eu
ce genre d feeling de clubs underground
anglais n'y manque de temps et puis
c'était juste quelque chose qui ce genre
de musique que tu écoutes tu commences
ta vie parce qu'ils avaient vraiment
plusieurs tournois ce que ça sonnait
comme
du depeche mode des années 80 m et jean
remis au goût du jour le puy -
évidemment ça me parle beaucoup ce que
je tripe là tu le mets vraiment
l'impression d'être dans des clubs en
deux grandes lalonde au récent pour ça
m'est il ya beaucoup d arrangements
aussi qui ont été faites pendant la
pandémie j'avais séparé de la pandémie
mais comme tu es moi j'en remets moyen
de couper c'était un sous sol chez nous
puis j'ai acheté plein de vieux de
lumière switch.com là j'ai quand même
des lasers le fidesz troubles depuis un
petit peu de boucane pilote chiche vu
qu'on ne fait pas sortir n'ai rien je
faisais un petit club chez nous qui dans
le fond tiges amont déneigés comme
commencé à m'écrire débit pendant la
journée je reviens du studio aps les
joueurs étaient un peu choqués mes
collègues du genre c'est comme s'ils
sont capables de danser ici on envie de
danser là dessus c'est bon j'ai quelque
chose si on peut autant envie de danser
faut que j'y retourne au studio piquer
comme georges augmente le seigneur je
sais pas quoi gens qui je pense que moi
il ya quelque chose de très que des
petites choses je me suis dont je me
suis ennuyé pendant pandémie qui est la
danse aller dans les bars dans ses
dépenses j'avais besoin de retrouver un
espèces d'espèces comme ça il pense que
la scène aussi le fait d'avoir parce que
j'écris 1er juin j'ai pas vraiment fait
de scène mais là on écrive ont depuis vu
que j'avais fait de la scène je savais
c'était quoi comment ça pouvait être un
spectacle commence à fait un oeuf mais
je sais à qui je vais m'écrire des toons
bon me garantir que ça va tourner au
pile comme des fiches en spectacle le
monde se fiche de la taille sur le
plateau de bure m'objecter sûr je te
commande ou un genre de rêve le
nouvel
album remix si on a fait comme premier
jury mixte qui est que le 1er juin mais
oui mix marque comme clint dj
montréalais qui ont intégré l'album we
mix dans l'ancien spectacle est de
nouveau fait que c'est quand même des
fois ça vire c'est juste mais ici c'est
vraiment cool ouais merci c'est cool de
voir justement ces privations luz espèce
de manque lui de la part de l'un a fait
en sorte qu ici comme devenu tout comme
contre-attaqué avec l' inverse le
flamand psicom kg maintenant on peut
faire des shows way fait que le ont fait
un show pour ce primeur pour toutes les
fois qu'on a fait ça pour ça mon job
c'est vraiment peu de m'apitoyer monde
entre collectif jusqu'à oui vous pensez
déjà aux choses enfin on y comptait
tourner à huawei mais surtout les
postures et en parle et on tourne mais
elle c'est vraiment la dernière tune que
j'ai écrit juste avant qu'on parte on a
fait comme une semaine au studio world
qui blaise mon réalisateur était
convoqué le s'est fini le tout les toons
counsel c'est maintenant on prend juste
ces huit là j'en avais une vingtaine on
prend 6,8 le puits en hiver si tout le
choc donc au menu des randonneurs fait
que l'agent par une semaine chez logic
fait le show dans mon studio que
jusqu'au à qui on fait la poste fera
king vidor avec le disque dur mais les
canons leader cgt dit le ce dernier
colonna mais finalement il écoute
quelqu'un à qui passe les tests noyade
l'époque est contente c'était vraiment
genre le bout de l'élastique ou parce
que j'étais le plus comme asti j'ai hâte
que ça reprenne elle dit ouais ouais
toujours une piste qui lui sera
toutefois on dirait le tourisme avec à
rien ça fait paraît il on avait une
toune compter comme pu puis satisfait
maintenant au pied on le faisait écouter
la loi mais du mont-de-piété comment ces
bombes c'est une leçon - préféré tout
comme étant ceux qui venaient mais avait
quelque chose dans
dans le son qui était cool mais sedan
sur haïti c'est comme plutôt qu'un bref
il est finalement c'est comme on était
déjà au mix pour la fête ok on
découpe et toutes les affaires fait une
nouvelle toune une section le milliard
plus j'avance ariane george school ce
qu'il a fait est un genre ces malades
pilon je finis tuna les deux semaines
petit également souvent c'est comme déjà
de deux tonnes que tu aimes le plus
parce que c'est
plus fun parce que le temps que ce train
depuis deux trois ans des français comme
jo
ouais j'ai comme eu le temps de les met
plus les mêlées mais plus l'aimer comme
quatorze fois nature tandis que ceux ci
comme juste genre contexte et on l'est
mon infinie ouais puis on la sent ces
pays ou si c'était encore un peu comme
toi un jour de bon augure pour genre
mais quand ça va faire du shopping
ça prend la tête
avec 20 tonnes ils sont si l'on imagine
plus ou moins avancés mais il arrive
quel format carte dit quand quand tes
calculs comme une toune c'est
à la bonne question parce que tu
m'étonnes j'imagine 2010
mille j'exagère sûrement leur métier
juste des fragments des verts de coupe
de paragraphes timide pour que tu
calcules quand j'en ai mais mettons dans
mon disque dur comment ça fonctionne
c'est pas une métaphore le bras dans
monde s'il
ya un fond de caisse est en chantier
puis un four 2 que c'est juste qu'un
prennent
souvent faiblesse qu'il fait le mélange
fois quand ça fonctionne et ce qui est à
moi j'ai mon petit tu as autrement les
genres je faisais je travaille dans le
four de en chantier fait que la maison
j'ai plein de morceaux le j'apporte le
disque dur à blaise mettant une fois par
semaine au club l'aise il fait comme
acquis et soyez du potentiel ça c'est
bon c'est cette génisse au monde sa
personne et j'aurais abandonné abandonné
sa move on est savamment preuve
face à la foule et ça devient une vraie
idée s'il y en a une coupe qui sont
allés dans pru depuis que finalement ils
ont été dangereux et après se retrouver
en chantier mais recalé puis quand tu
arrives à 20 jeunes s'est également
attaché aux chansons non voyons là une
coupe qui sont pas sortis puisque je
devrais la finir j'aimerais me forcer à
trouver quelque chose pour que ça
fonctionne
mais ce travail là
moi je trouve qu'ils quittent moi ce que
vous en pensez mais je trouve que c'est
capital parce que dernièrement mettons
des gros artistes qui sortent des albums
j'écoute leurs albums il ya 25 tonnes
dans 25 qui en treize qui n'ont pas
d'enfant sur un album que t'as que tu
payes pour écouter maintenant le
mouvement tabarnak à toutes les fois le
check up veut pas croire resté 25 tonnes
que vous ne faites écouter sur puits qui
rend pas de votre côté on dirait de
travail de sélection de concision qui a
été fait par la concision entre en
littérature comment moi je n'ai appris
dans mon parcours c'était
c'est un enjeu important
tout commence et que ton premier jet de
romans mettant 400 pages plus et en veut
deux semblaient temps veut pas de 400
les pages de 200 vaches concise avec le
prêt de concision me semble important
que tu en penses eh bien je pense qu'il
ya une réponse qui est quand même
physique dans le sens où avant mes
tontons
minimes 1 [ __ ] maximum physiquement tu
peux pas aller plus loin si tu veux
aller plus loin faut que tu fasses un
deuxième vinyles il après ça c'est
vraiment à feindre extrêmement rare un
album de troisvilles fait que ça faisait
comme une frontière psychologique un
seul cd je sais pas c'est quoi la limite
son incident il accueille 120 minutes
120 minutes
des deux hommes n'est pas extrêmement
mais je sais pas si c'est comme les
plateformes de diffusion qui fait que
les gens sur carottes ses cd mp3 ou des
web fait quand même temps couvert en mp
oui moi je pense que c'est ce que moi je
pense que genre de chiffres que l'album
ait vu qu'ils immatériel plus souvent
c'est maintenant il comme on est perçu
comme genre une oeuvre
n'oeuvrait d'or que tu consommes
c'est plus comme des toons comme
quasiment team et ont été les derniers
albums de métro kanye west et drake ce
sera plus simple et les scans albums
récents drames ashton sont le pij a plus
maître de tourner plus m'ont pas surpris
au début de l'album où jean lemaître
random plus ça fait de stream dans leurs
eaux faire la fête je pense qu'il ya une
affaire un peu commerciale abidal déjà
manqué les plateformes fonctionne
puisque juste plus tu tournes plus tu
exprimes +1 ce qui fait que ces soucis
c'est moins perçu suppose que tu es un
outil pour ceux qui conquit on qui ont
peu dormi la nuit a seulement dit que
c'est quoi alors parfait nord qui compte
500 chansons albums puis je fais sur un
livret avec les paroles puis des
illustrations qui comme en corée tout
layton peut être impossible
parce qu'il avait ajouté l'ex led par
des soucis les artistes
c'est un être comme un disciple
d'artistes le moral et je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup aussi des
d'artistes qui ont le souci de l'album
ces pics comme devoir se commande comme
hors jeu souvent qu'autrement c'est
encore the way mais c'est moins en moins
consommer
mais non moins en moins je sais pas si
et des artistes que tu veux écouter leur
album complet bien que tu peux plus
écouter des détenus mais
beaucoup de monde c'est moi j'écoute des
albums puis tout est codé mais il
beaucoup de monde qui écoute la paix le
café montréalais s'est recueillie ils
connaissent une tonne de 45 artistes
ça arrive beaucoup peut-être mettons le
été un coup de coeur tout écouter
l'album est déjà
beaucoup de monde écoute des playlists
écoutant l'album ou écoutent de la
musique sur internet ce qui fait que
telle est le moment où est-ce que tout
mais j'ai porté le
vinyle cd baissent de moments
cérémonieux héritier du début à la fin
d'une manière quand même relativement
conséquent très active
c'est
ça m'étonne album il ya pensé pour être
écoutés comme seul parce que maintenant
moi j'aurais pas pu tantôt tantôt je
voulais le mettre en courant parce que
je me suis jamais me concentrer dessus
parce que je pourrais pas le mettre en
arrière en background piller vraiment
capté le message que dans voiture parce
que je veux passer des textes quand même
somme toute un peu hermétique pitié
quand même complexe de compréhension le
fait qu est ce que tu le penses de même
quand tu écris ton album tu dis tu je
vais le faire pour que les gens
l'écoutent
c'est soit que tout le monde envie
d'être écoutés mais j'essaie d'être
quand même perméable au fait que je skie
les gens c'est quoi le moyen optimal que
les gens écoutent ma musique parce
qu'ici c'était vraiment ce qui me devais
je pense que je ferai un peu d'autres
choses
je pense pas que ce que je souhaite
c'est nécessairement la chose la plus
facile à écouter la même manière que des
fois tu penses à mettant un titre de
film tu es comme à ce film le sens de
l'écouté mais c'est tough d'une heure
aujourd'hui j'ai une grosse journée qui
je pense pas que j'ai envie d'écouter
la métaphysique de la ville a les
ressources du bon mais lieu à fond j'ai
le goût de
fixer ce genre si je voulais plus faire
qu'une du fast food j'en ferais je pense
que je serai comme enfermé comme moi le
but c'est que ce soit plus des espèces
d'être d'aventuré des avants du os qui
est gentil commis depuis dit que j'y
vais et éventuellement une fois que tout
est adoptée l'album je
l'écouté parce qu'ils étaient en zone
connue mais j'imagine qu'au début c'est
un peu confrontant d'être comme je pas
sûr de comprendre mais c'est comme le
but non plus c'est pas de comprendre
c'est pour ça que la musique ou sinon
c'est que c'est pas un récital de textes
l'inté c'est quand même s'il comprend
rien même si par une autre langue qui
peut aimer la bonne part et parce qu'ils
étaient quand même j'avais pensé
le
le voyage semble aussi qu'en mai ou du
moins plusieurs locations dans le monde
semblent au centre de temps de ton
oeuvre puis que c'est quoi la place que
ça le le voyage puis l'importance de
changer d'horizon pour être capable de
créer mais j'ai toujours voyagé beaucoup
genre j'ai eu l'occasion d'être dans une
famille parce que c'est vraiment comme
c'est important pour mes parents
effectivement voix yéti ton parvient but
où il est français de base ce sont eux
qui s et c'est son grand-père à lui et
polonais que l'enfant d'où le nom et
piégeant rim a mené en a qu'un
c'est quand même évident
qu'avec mon père aussi c'est pas genre
et les voyages 5 étoiles c'est comme
karachi avait déjà
allés non ok en tout cas c'est vraiment
une aventure c'est vrai qu'entre qu'un
exemple c'est quelqu'un qui veut ça
paraît bien précis je vais en grèce avec
une maison mipi genre en turquie avec ma
mère puisque éventuellement j'ai 18 ans
pile je vais genre thaïlande gm j'habite
à bali abandonné et puis c'est que fabio
taborre mais parce que mon père y avait
déménagé à bali fait que j'allais le
voir comme ponctuellement pierre mondy
je pensais quand même trop quatre mois
la bonne c'est que c'est comme si les
voyages de formation là haut juste comme
voir d'autres choses vivre d'autre chose
avant cette survient à la maison j'étais
comme acquis et c'est bon les tiges
rallier des affaires qui sont comme plus
je sais pas je sais pas si juste c'est
juste des expériences qui s'achète pas
nulle part j'en fais juste que tu le vif
puis moi je sus l'occasion la grande
chance l'énorme privilège de le faire
c'est parce que j'avais des parents que
ceux qui voulaient investir là dedans
fixe terroristes et qui quand je me suis
dit je sortis de création littéraire de
l'udem puis jetée comme qui est logé
j'ai envie de retourner voyager mais en
même temps j'ai envie de faire la
musique je lui dis je juste tout mettre
mes oeufs dans le même panier qui est la
musique bien mais de parenté va en piste
vous voulez changer en communication je
fasse une maîtrise lafarge et comment je
fais de la musique chauffeur dur qui met
deux ballons gens non il ya donné tout
ce qu'on pouvait y en a maintenant tu
vas devenir diplomate a tendance à se
répéter pendant depuis acheté comme fuck
you pas ça prend quand même dose de fuck
you did faire ce que tu veux c'est que
là je me suis dit je vais choquer
surtout du rec fait qu'il ait jeté comme
je vais travailler le plus fort que je
peux pour retrouver le voyage le plus
vite possible tim peel justement grâce à
premier joueur on est allé en france on
est allé en belgique et on est allé dans
des petites villes comme vendôme parce
qu'on s'est fait christophe parce qu'on
faisait trop de bruit des petites vies
notre but on s'est fait crisser d'ordre
commence à réussir sa vie
c'est les élections faisant un show dans
une église et le line up je pense que
lahoud lisier peines qui pillent les
week-ends jamais c'est comme
elle est libellée et comme on est dans
une église avant donc pire genre 200
personnes
dans le match qui y avaient rails mais
aussi et c'est vraiment une trappe et
mois d'août de rap et moi qui l'ait
c'était le soir des élections
canadiennes fait que je pense que
c'était une des fois que justin trudeau
est rentré qui ont été dans notre
chambre d'hôtel puis on écoute et on
écoutait sur un ordi puis on avait plus
gai l'ordi dans un ampli pour qu'elles
augmentent ils sont comptés comme 15
dans une chambre d'hôtel et l'autre avec
elle elle est aussi août et jusqu'à
maintenant les gars étaient là mais on
n'est pas non plus
ouais mais il n'était pas assez solide
on ne fait laptop après c'est à cause du
décalage horaire on accompagne été
confondues 3 heures du matin planté dans
l'hôtel dit le jaune
l'ampli à 10 des pions crié lors des
résultats puis 19 le lendemain
stéphane lemieux mon batteur il toque
ouais c'est ça faut pas qu'on s'en aille
que maintenant on est dans une autre
nuit t on va pas s'en aller j'avais
comme non non on se fait crisser d'or de
l'hôtel et que là je parlais à la madame
qui est comme amenons ne peut pas on a
des japonais
compétents on a des japonais mais c'est
que au québec il ya des gens de
visiteurs japonais avec lens fait
crisser dehors de l'hôtel l'on appelle
le guide du festival pour nicolas ce
sont ces foetus edwards un auto tel le
guen ou relocalise méjean le village d'à
côté le genre sur feu du lot et les
échos via personnes qui dansent de vous
prendre que vous allez à côté l'aiglon
avait la chambre de merde d'un genre le
site ville de l'île bagne le soir
jean-christophe paquin gros on s'est
fait chrysler devant dont c'était le
rush à colleret à cause qu'on vivait
note rock en écoutant les élections
fédérales
c'est moi qui te tourner dès le week end
et ouais c'est quand même break cacao
grecque je dis ça dépend des finances un
souhait moi je suis peu je fais pas je
fais pas des grosses drug le fait que
maintenant un chouette c'est genre cet
aspect ne durera que je l'aimais je peux
je n'aime pas les gens on doit faire ce
qu'ils veulent c'est jusqu'à six mois je
suis plus ce
parti
jim webb a naïvement je mets vraiment où
souvent le fait que c'est que même si
j'essaie de cet aspect du rock - et
métiers juste ce nom c'est hot seat est
allé trop loin je n'avais partie du truc
le lendemain en général le lendemain de
guigues mois comme moniteur parce que
j'essaie de rien le bouquet puis que à
moins qu'ils aient un autre choix
évidemment mais le lendemain de guide
pour moi c'est une méthode qu'il faut
que je respecte le chum le j'ai dormi
genre trois heures il fallu rentrer
illustrent ces gens aussi les gens ils
pensent que comme si je pense que pour
venir au large chip reese qui vous
laissera les pieds à la nonchalance et
c'est important pour moi d'être
nonchalante en spectacle d'être aussi
c'est l'espace où est ce que j'ai pu et
d'inhibition puis je fais genre tout ce
que je veux puis georges et les gens ma
main puis genre c'est ce qui se passe
super nes mais c'est sûr qu'après cité
la discipline revivre c'est comme la
discipline avant et après qui me permet
pas un spectacle d'être genre de faire
n'importe quoi s'il est évident et pas
avoir une petite bande d'une attaque du
genre c'est une correction n'est tuées à
banache la bonne couleur roux discipline
ô ma gueule
nom à l'album
nom d'un d'individus des guitares des
diocèses de john petrucci
mais honnêtement et marcel sensu
pratique
si tu pratiques tu es bon tu pratiques
ce que tu fais tu vas être bon c'est sûr
que c'est tout
c'est important les les période de
battement le tu parles de tête de ton de
la journée landemaine l'enseigné ou
est-ce que tu planifie rien d période de
battement comme sur un ré après quelque
chose de tellement intense c'est
vraiment important pour redescendre mais
des fois tu regardes le ton les deux
tournées d'artistes internationaux c'est
comme tu regardes la liste c pendant
deux mois toutes les sources petit gamin
ça peut arriver c'était tout le temps un
mode ja c'est tout le temps fatigué
aille au plus haut point j'arrête devant
stadium puis j'arrête le monde qui t'ont
mon métier puis la présente même pas le
temps de décanter de ce que le lendemain
ça recommence encore et tu te jure le
temps de prendre un avion pour ramener
de recommencer une
seconde aiguë je vois quand on est au
québec parce que le lundi mardi mercredi
ce post crise et mollo cessez-le-feu qui
ne coule pas vrai parce qu'il ya
tellement de villes en france ou aux
states que tu peux faire des geeks dans
chaque ville puis honnêtement mon ami tu
souhaites tu dois juste devenir un
fantôme comme chaque salle devient la
même des justes dans des blocs noirs
tout le temps j'imagine que les gens
sont dits tous internationaux ils font
juste quand il parle à personne ils font
le moins de trucs postuler mais sont
toujours dans le jeu ne sorte pas après
il s'est juste comme tu reach un nouveau
niveau discipline où est-ce que taken 2
pôles choisi non
la semaine passée j'étais en tournée
avec est patrice munsch all way puis en
est faite en fait deux jours ils sont
issus de leurs accusations
mollo prêté
son pépère il ya le donald bayne qui
boivent du thé chaï
la majorité du stade on est comme
soldats qui ont besoin comme tout de la
centrale que puis-je à ses autres ont
tenté ont
des familles et tifa quel autre c'est
comme quand arrive la tournée
c'est comme qui arrive c'est comme le
temps avec la famille stack la famille
puis non seulement ce mais c'est qu'ils
mentent il est à mon tour de participer
parce que c'était ma blonde qui était
maison pendant toute la semaine et comme
j'étais embarqué dans un van pour partie
aux intel en gaspésie cinq jours et fait
qu'on ait fait en tout cinq semaines
confie une journée de route cinq shows
du rhin dreux puis la première
conversation d'arval c'était et aux
autres votre bêtise que tu mets autour
du cou les pour dormir vous l'avez pas
vous l'avez pris ou ti alors celui où
jean coutu est vraiment un club anglais
type c'est comme si c'est les
conversations si j'arrive d'autres vous
couchez vous les prenez ioukos cobain
wal mart ces genres ça sent la sueur et
les taxis ces drones frappent fois par
rock mais même à ce même si sion
finissait les choses rentrent et on se
couche et ont dormi huit ans
tavel quand élevé déjeuner
j'avais le temps faire du sport j'avais
le temps des genres travail la mise à
faire on est ferme sans tchèque on
allait super on alpha le chemin de se
coucher c'était très très très soft
c'est pas d'une erreur qui m'a menacé
après cinq jours de comme étant que ça
finisse pas ce qu'il brûle brûle et
juste le fait patcher juge g soit audrey
khelcom je checke des bnc mettons
ces ménages choses qui sont des amis à
moi de ses autres c'est comme le
retourner chez climatique
ils font des deux trois mois non-stop
lequel jouait avec moi tous les jours
c'est comme
je sais pas si j'aurais fait pour ça
c'est vraiment quelque chose c'est que
ça s'apparente vraiment à une épreuve de
sport d'endurance mettons ces mettons
les genres le tour de france le tour de
france le sait à tout les jours il ya
trois jours trois semaines
la seconde qui sont pus sur leur vélo la
seconde qui débarque gens sont en mode
récupération pour le lendemain je laime
cinq jeunes il racontait celui dit des
fois le lui arriver aux boules au bout
de l'étape mettons le il sortait de son
vélo
instantanément puis le chaque seconde à
partir de ce moment le jusqu'à temps que
sur son vélo le lendemain pour
s'échauffer pour pouvoir commencer était
dédiée à la récupération les germes et
on y avait 1 15 heures de bus pour
rentrer à l'hôtel il dormait avec 15
buts de bus agressé sur peut-être à
bussy manger la seconde qui a fini de
manger ils sont à relever ses jambes
dans un service pharmacie bessèges en
entier tout est vraiment axé sur juste à
40 de leur fort le lendemain mon dieu
que je comprends pas si tu fais pas ça
je comprends pas comment tu pourrais
arriver à est aussi maître toi même tu
sais qu'il y en a qui au final sont pas
tout le temps en mode performance ultime
jeudi son cas mais il y en a un petit
peu les les performances une question
d'être fait pour ses comptes exclure des
mauges à
quelqu'un qui aime la routine mal de
chine ou du genre est dans les affaires
dites que c'est aussi la situation
sociale suppose tout est comme son
métier moi mettons
moi ce que j'ai trouvé le plus dur en
fait c'était comme d'être quasiment tout
le temps avec ce bond à 5
ex mondsi comme est en mode conversation
bien en mode tout le temps elles doivent
interagir du monde et dans ma vie
l'habitude de tout seul dans ma pièce
qui est je m'excuse gosse l'afad seul
sait si comme le cheval de contrer comme
d'ailleurs
presque 100% du temps 5 et comme je venu
le brûlé se situe à une altitude la
tournée c'est quelque chose genre si tu
n est ok
et confortable qui est inconfortable
c'est toujours inconfortable être dans
des lieux que tu connais pas mais en
même temps ça fait partie de l'espèce de
d'adrénaline bénéfique mais c'est sûr
qu'il faut que tu 8,7 toutes tes repères
tout le temps tu es dans un nouvel
endroit une nouvelle pièce est décédé
nouveau fille nouveau technicien qui
connaît peu il ya comme un genre d
autiste qui veulent te parler le tice et
comme il est connu de tout le temps
quelque chose qu'il faut qu'un genre il
faut qu'il parle à des gens pied moi des
fois j'ai de la difficulté aussi à être
comme vraiment film quand je veux je
veux faire quelque chose s'est agi comme
un jeu juste plug et mes fils puis comme
passé à l'hôte étape avec des fois j'ai
de la jay un peu d'impatience était
quand même huit personnes qui viennent
me parler plus qu est-ce qu en train de
travailler dessus de faire le centre
tchèque qui pour le spectacle t c'est
comme ça va me faire plaisir de parler
après mais je trouve qu'il ya vraiment
un poids social que peut-être quelqu'un
le plus extraverti que moi aurait plus
de facile à faire de facilité à faire
mais c'est comme je suis pas quelqu'un
de si extraverti kseur des fois j'en
fais que j'y aille pauvres est quelque
chose qui ne serait ce qu'un ex chose
que je veux faire si je veux pas être
des jusqu'à ce que ce soit fait j'aime
mieux le faire plutôt que te parler je
perds du temps tu fait des fois je
trouve cette offre des fois j'ai eu
comme des interactions plus pesant plus
gentilhomme qui viennent ce qui m'a
embêté mais c'est comme ça voire juste
que je veux que ce soit comme ce que
j'ai en fait en train de faire de quoi
quand même parler ouais c'est ça mais
c'est comme les gens des fois ils
pensent que je suis comme tout le temps
me des animations publiques ces impies
des fois non le des fois je vais être un
souper puis je veux comme presque rien
dit ou des fois je prends ma parole qui
est drôle puisque homme s'arrête nice
mais comme c'est le fun avoir le choix
mais c'est comme des fois tu vends
région si je peux être commun montréal
aux centristes mais les gens et en plus
comme une dynamique de village
connaissent tout le monde c'est normal
que tu seras quelques parties présentes
diallo moi je m'appelle leeds à gens ici
je peux me présenter au monde dans la
bus je veux juste rentrer puis j'en sais
ma vie c'est mais dans des plus petites
villes
c'est pas la même chose fake c'est
important de bonjour tout le temps de se
présenter barbe c'est quelque chose que
j'ai appris à mes dépends que genre au
début j'étais comme je serai très ferme
et chypre déjanté comme
c'est que moi ce jeudi ce qui était avec
tout le temps avec le monde je sais
quand même nice comme mon berne parce
que c'est comme si ma sécurité frêche
comme je me sens bien avec eux c'est
comme mon équipe ii j'aurais mais qu'en
même temps je prends une pause avant
souper pour faire mon maquillage puis
tous les autres humains qui peuvent et
qui vont super puma de façon j'aime
passer sous peu savant chanter je me
sens que andy gestion piger pas comme on
energy team high tech c'est ça mais
c'est mon moment où est ce que georges
seul avec moi-même et ma petite musique
jetable serviettes sales fans mais le
show qu'on monte est tellement exigeante
qui avons su jouer de la guitare
jeandupeux la première fois qu'on a fait
le show c'est à sherbrooke mais on le
fait tout exauce c'est comme notre soft
lunch viendrait sont le fait à
sherbrooke chus ohmydollz j'avais pas
réalisé à quel point ça allait me coûter
cher au niveau énergétique de faire ce
show le jeu j'ai plus de 8 puis j'ai des
toons quand même dance fait que l'essai
jusqu'au 6 juin les troupes c'est juste
que c'est faux l'entente genre puisque
omagad ça me prend la technique de chant
fait que je retourne dans les cours de
chant puis je retourne faire mon cardio
à tous les jours puis je retourne que
retourner dans la discipline du rock
j'ai pas le choix c'est steve bruce
dickinson de da chanteur d'armé donne
lui il était reconnu pour être le gueux
qui courent genre un marathon à chaque
spectacle qui est lui dedans un dvd
jours après un beau trou ce que je ferai
ma in tout
y est y avait un dvd dans le dvd genre
il disait aussi tout le show fini il
apparaît que les autres jouent le match
traite ça comme une épreuve sportive le
fait que jean lui pour être capables de
faire ce genre un show exigeant même qui
courait que le drapeau de l'angleterre
genre près partout le ballon chaud le
fallait alex wall comme si y'avait jeu
demain quand je parlais même seringue
bartoli le traitement mais c'est un
menteur pourvu qu'ils apprécient
j'essaie de penser que c'est comme c'est
quoi le sport qui t'empêche de respirer
apport le chant bien précis je me suis
bien fait tout les sports nautiques et
être la natation c'est le même concept
ces gens c'est le seul sport qui
t'oblige restreinte à respiration c'est
fucking difficile ouais on faisait des
exercices les autres natation 10 puis
c'est le genre d'affaires qui s'en voit
vraiment j'ai encore pas mal ces jours
ci le ce jardin facteurs qui s'en va
vite c'est enfin on appelait cela de
l'hypoxie fait que ces genres c'est une
limite des respirations encore plus
grandes banques quand tu nages
normalement déjà qu'en temps normal je
peux prendre un but de respiration qui
est constant mais là dessus les met
encore plus pour respirer le moins
possible dans les longueurs d'onde puis
on en faisait beaucoup de dieu avant le
thé puis on était meilleur que je suis
maintenant tu le jeune enfant il ya déjà
fort que j'étais capable de faire on
était bien concentré n'est plus que le
juste plus capable de faire avec ça tu
en dit long sur comment notre corps
s'adapte à ce genre d'affaires le
justement de courir en chantant
barras mang et apparemment bien de ses
jardins à s'entraîne maintenant à courre
sur le tapis roulant puis à celle ci
tournent un court insultez pas les
moyens c'est un menteur et c'est en fait
une couple de fois je le fais le ce que
méchant vélo il est j'y mets thoune sont
les paroles qu'elle chante par dessus
c'est tellement turf le sens bon et
c'est extrêmement juste gai écoute
quelqu'un qui joue à arles et
l'innovation par utile
par les basses que celles sur les
parkings thaïs
l'exposer dans cette zone là quand on
fait du bac ou relaxes dont
je parle est
donc en cours chemin trop bien que j'ai
couru un déni et marathon à côté de toi
on parlait pas fanfaron
enfin ne jeter muet
ça a été long terme et ample de tulle
donc si on allait visiter des des locaux
pour le studio a prévu des retards dans
la charité quand même j y pensais pas
[Rires]
être à la fois que tu fais tout ça n'est
pas fausse fait un effort
pause jusqu'à un point si jamais poussé
ouais ça
ça doit avoir des entraînements d'arts
martiaux sur wiiware partiellement c'est
tellement comme cardio mais musculaire
en même temps dans les zones
mais c'est ça pour ma chanson harbor
dans le fond j'ai fait un clip dans
lequel je jouais l'enfant on joue avec
les codes si l'analogie ce du boxeur
mais dans le fond c'était un combat
ultime que je pense je suis qui lie au
fc ouais c'est seb encaissés c'est
l'univers mais tant pis je faisais déjà
du gesù que je me suis dit là il faudra
que je m'entraîne que je travaille mon
va être mon muay thaï fait que j'avais
un entraîneur privé deux fois par
semaine c'était tellement tu es quand
même que bettman pour une vidéo que le
plus ouais je sais c'est un trou c'est
demain
doucement mais gentil gens pendant
quatre mois c'était sa piste est juste
que j'avais envie de vomir à chaque fois
c'est vrai un menteur puis après ce jeu
télé chez nous puisque je fais rien
faire jusqu'à fait que ben justement
brûlé métier petit à petit du rhône
alpes mais c'est ouais c'est comme
extrêmement cardio puis extrêmement
musculaire qui sait aussi comme pas jeu
vidéo mais dans son souffre ok tu
réagisses avec le s'apprend
oui c'est sa maison mythique qui est
assez important aussi réception
dictacteur ces genres qui se savent
luxueux acquis sauf que je fasse le hsg
réagit une seconde trop tard je me
techniquement je me serais fait genre
ouais ce feeling l'homme étant d'avoir
envie de vomir mais
des fois des fois mes temps quand je me
casse le pouce ofcom je tapais j'ai fait
que le marathon d'ottawa bleus deux
semaines qu'est puis pendant les
derniers comme 5 km du genre vraiment eu
un genre de coup de chaleur puis en plus
c'était les derniers 5 km et que j'ai
j'ai payé le plus court et plus je me
disais j'aimerais soumettons prendre
quelqu'un qui sait jamais vraiment mis
dans cette situation leur ai donc puis
juste pendant 5 secondes qu'ils soient
dans mon corps en ce moment pour
j'aurais réalisé comme que ça se peut
maintenant amener son corps le laisse
toujours j'ai vu julie à l'abdomen et à
la partager une photo de toi qui sortait
du crossfit non c'était comme cela avec
comme de l'eau par jean ségalat il vient
d'aller au bout
de ce que tu es capable de faire mais
c'est autant de navarre m une fois que
je reviens dessus aussi le meilleur
feeling monde entier
quand j'ai d'aller au bout terrassement
au bout de ce que j'étais capable de
faire physiquement plus plus loin que ça
j'allais mourir ou tomber par terre ou
en filature viennent de nous ses
meilleurs fils et mon choix c'est drôle
parce que c'est cette idée le mettant
des gens équine qui innove qui rentrait
dans mon cas un moment précis mais tant
pis gens expérimentés pendant comme trop
ça comme un jeu
en faisant quoi maintenant mais j'en
refais danse du crossfit en fait
j'aimerais ça se calme et on est quand
je me suis baril de l'autre
bouger je me disais que quelqu'un puisse
comprendre ces contacts comme la douleur
ce serait cool on aurait tous beaucoup
plus d'empathie pour eh oui c'est sûr
personnes en situation d'handicap web
des personnes les moyens nouveaux types
et que mésanges à reviendront encore
cinq secondes qui expérimentent qu'est
ce que j'étais en train de vivre parce
que ça
ou même inversement mettons cartes
étendu un show en plein de comm super
c'est quoi le mot que cherche
moi mais sur l'adrénaline c'est pas
demain je vais prendre ce moulin de
l'autre ne me viendrait pas le meilleur
sur l'adrénaline à fond là ça va
peut-être autant christ et sa tête de
quoi expérimenté mais tronquée j'en ai
bien encore cinq secondes
absolument puis après c'était dans un
motel dégueulasse en banlieue de
gatineau que vient mon corps ça se peut
pas que je
pilote ok c'est fini demain ils étaient
encore paul d'énergie pékin à quai dans
le france le faut je me cassais
s'endorment faut que je donne parce que
d'un maillon d'un réchaud ja
c'est le meilleur
tout le monde parce que le mont tout
simplement dans ce métier le côté
visible du truc de faire genre de
musique faire des choses c'est quoi le
bout de charme à l'adq mais j'ai
tellement tout le tout les dessous
programmée
l'après shoah les hôtels
les loges avec l'art de chip deux sacs
de chips lay's céline aigle rouge fm et
déjà ce que pense qu est ce que le monde
pense que c'est backstage c'est comme ça
un gros party
que c'est vraiment c'est comme genre
4-4
déjà zimeray décide de changer bien
comme genre 8 bars but je pense bac à
bac tout le temps petit chose que
j'essaie juste des cages
qu'est ce qui s'en vient cet été pour
toi dans les terres sans makoun eh bien
on est beaucoup de festivals l ai fait
qu je pense on joue avec une barbe noire
puis à chaud sauvage wcs caennaise c'est
le show qu'on a fait à santa surtout
bonne question je sais pas je m'appelle
que sûrement sa deuxième semaine
le pigeonnier les prix génie c'est ce
sont non
traditionnels patrick promet d'être de
dimanche on invite à la fête dans le
temps la deuxième scène était ailleurs
un endroit qu'on appelait le pigeonnier
je sais quelle raison c'est comme dans
le jargon garder ce nom le danger du
monde de québec qui vont en effet qu ça
s'appelle encore l'épicé
cgc après les plaines tu vas avec les
chaudes artiste qui ait besoin ok ok bon
gelais pialat nos soucis s'arrête
vraiment le fun avant daniel bélanger
c'est le prix que devrait payer d'autres
choses à faire que chacun peut partir en
tout cas serrée de chéquier sur internet
on clique sur des plateformes j sinon
personnellement pour toi quelque chose
que tu parles tu qu'est ce qui se passe
dans ta vie
est foutue ddd dessus incombe à paris
non non non mais en fait j'aimerais
attendre sa pente raide faire ça donc de
battre je pense que j'ai le niveau là
les gens et bien sur mac et que ton
niveau qui veut se battre aussi - et
peut-être mais je pense que cheminement
pratique est encore là en tête jean ça
va être mon projet de
30 est
abandonnée je vais être tranquille et ça
fait longtemps que j'en fais je pense
que je pourrais faire de quoi mais non
je me fais je me fais régulièrement
battre
les exercices mais dont tu te fais
régulièrement taper ouais mais c'est
cool parce que ça donne aussi une autre
honnêtement je mettrais au défi gens
n'importe quel gars avaient passé une
journée au jim je m'entraîne ou taille
l'angle cesson jean-talon sais c'est que
tu comprends je comprends que quelqu'un
peut être féminin et puis frappé des
choses aussi lutter je pense que c'est
vraiment une autre définition de la
féminité comme décors extrêmement musclé
qui reste féminin est si gentil comme je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup de gossip qui on
parle de frapper sur les filles c mais
je pense que c'est confrontant metz et
nice aussi de se dire que tu es je
frappe et un peu moins fort peu taille
puisqu'elle clairement une différence
physique mais mécénat esprit je pense
que honnêtement les arts martiaux le je
pense que je pense qu'il est si j'ai
juste un petit peu juste assez d'un
petit peu de violence en moi pour être
comme être contente tu mets ton et fois
je suis fort chips comme auch en colère
mais c'est comme c'est tellement plus
simple de frapper dans un truc pas
souvent les gens sont frappés passé
violent mais c'est quand même c'est
tellement encadrée comme forme de
violence c'est tellement un jeu comme
quand titi rails avec ton frère la sage
c'est tellement il ya des règles et
comme des petites frappes pas sur la
colonne vertébrale il ya des trucs c'est
que je pense que tout le monde
bénéficierait de ce ballet jean mathon
qui ont beaucoup d'énergie
la canalise vraiment truc c'est que
quelqu'un qui est consentant pour que tu
le feras plus il y en a pas de problème
cette violent avec quelqu'un que j'en
peu dit oui gestique des fois je peux
être violente verbalement aussi quand je
suis comme j'en agressés par les trucs
mais ça c'est le genre de truc qui me
lis est à 100 jusqu'à hier je peux
vraiment comme faire face c'est prouvé
scientifiquement que ça tu meurs avec
n'importe quel autre source de stress
après avoir fait supporte pas moi qui
mettons le genre du jugement sur le mais
quand je viens m'entraîner le jeu pour
être dans le trafic ne tombe le ghana va
- à la lumière pourrait devenir ouverte
puis je pourrais attendre la lumière
retombe roux je rentre de faire quoi que
ce soit pour y dire d'avancé mettons un
jeu tellement comme aucune envie de
farol je voyais klaxonner c'est
justement grâce avec l'accent du cycle à
savoir sa vie ta vie mais n'osent pas
c'est quoi ta vie qui fait que tu
regardes pas la lumière le tigre est il
fera de donner mes amis que lui il ya eu
une période de sa vie où est ce qu il
sortait d'un bar qui se battaient sur un
site elle m'a battue
les suites fight ses hôtes à regarder
les moi j'avoue là bas c'est pour garder
js bach c'est la chose que 14 jeux pour
ce que la boxe police parle ayew et
cissé aussi populaire fondée en mars you
ça va être les derniers à se battre dans
un bar il exact
ouais puis aussi c'est ça existait déjà
kitchen je pense que c'est maintenant
comme considérés comme des armes
blanches ou charlie écarté comme un
maître d'arts martiaux et tuer quelqu'un
que tu aimerais facilement
mais bref c'est le
problème
c'est à chaque fois
un problème puis jordi au point que tu
es dans la famille c'était comme l'y par
interview au point de jeudi des colis de
la maison non plus comme
c'était ce matin puisque le ya découvert
le mmm je sais pas quelle quelle est la
version masculine mais j'avais découvert
subissent à colmar ils sont c'est comme
trouver la manière de canaliser cette
espèce de truc le contexte encore dry ce
qui peut comme sur sur se régler en
pigeant
[Musique]
sur cette belle histoire sur cette belle
histoire merci beaucoup d'être venu
à
[Musique]
a2 du contenu excellent tu as tout un
podcast combien
oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur le titre i entre le pitch vous
abonner pour trop dollars par mois c'est
trop de longs mois et trois pièces par
l'as par mois et vous avez les pas de
carte en avance xavier premier de votre
groupe d'amis avoir quitté les podcasts
qu'ils allaient avoir pouvoir avoir une
avance quand vous allez tuer le la
dynamique entre les amuse tout le temps
avec une avance sur les jobs en avance
je rentre de toi mais avec pétillante en
avance sur l'humanité complète en plus
en plus parce que le chèque le parc a su
ni voulu nous entendre avantage on fait
des encore moins de filtres à préchac
podcast avec là on vient de finir de
tourner le podcast on va en jaser on va
toucher les nicole non nicole il est
maintenant évident comme un fils
travaille à plat ce détail est là mais
on jason par la conversion convient
d'avoir mais ce si vous voulez avoir
accès
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous c'est exclusif
sur pékin il faut s'abonner abonnez vous